who owns  silence the lambs silence of the lambs  is owned by mgm  and so what what happened  early on and why there was sort of like  kind of a sticking point  for us with the the the clarisse rights  is that  mgm was originally working on a deal  with martha delaurentis that had  everything in  one like package and  then galmont came along and offered  martha a significantly  you know greater deal that mgm couldn't  match  and so there's been a little bit of  animosity between the studios because  mgm's like hey you were gonna do it with  us and she was like yeah but you didn't  give me the better deal and they were  kind of upset about that so that's why  it's been sort of like a sticking point  to try to get  the clarice rights because they were  like why would we help you  when you like they're basically bill  pullman  and sleepless in seattle  good analogy